today's topic we got a video from
jubilee originally I just want to react
to this but this turned into an
accidental cringe report so tune in and
tell us at which point you might have
checked out if you cringe just as hard
[Music]
I'm Pyrrhic so I'm 24 I'm Stephanie
Feinberg I am 43 years old
and if I could describe our relationship
you know what's interesting just
listening to these two right off the top
I get the impression that he is just as
old this year's not like looks-wise but
just in the way they carry themselves
you know when you hang around be water
older than you at some point there's
some things that you're gonna drop we
were asked for sure for sure right now I
mean like because I was hanging around
the Friends of my sister with just three
years and a half older than me right I
was just that dude yeah that's how they
do it in college all right let me lower
my voice a bit because I have to be
around them I they don't want to be a
nuisance rock paper scissors oh my god
was that so how about you just you go
rock okay just put your hand down you
would always tell how much it goes into
dude why when she laughs at jokes that
aren't funny
[Laughter]
[Music]
I didn't try to say German relax man
geez but it made me nervous because I
was worried that you really liked me so
intense that's a pretty loud laugh you
know saying now they're gonna be like
see they're not only best friends
they're lovers okay I would describe our
relationship as like like a volcano just
in Mount Vesuvius just like like just
boiling underneath a saute pan
you know just preparing for this
medium-rare steak okay he's like at the
beets up and I'm like the fire the
language barrier but her metaphor sucks
chicken and I'm like the stove and don't
have Thome chicken better true
Salmonella this is a good question
actually so we actually had an argument
and where I stand is that I don't really
know exactly and I kind of prefer it
that way it's like he was talking for
her like I said in our argument I don't
really know and I like it better that
way
thank you can we move on cuz we have a
reservation it's at 9:00 it's 9:45 we're
standing outside talking about this we
could be eating some good chicken right
now remember the stove yeah the stove
makes it better okay I want it like that
yeah our relationship is like the
perfect representation of like a digital
postmodern world where there are
absolutely no labels no gender and no
age or like anything to define what the
hell were experiencing in this short
amount of three months and if I could
find a label to describe what the hell
just happened I would be nearly
impossible it's my boyfriend
yo Jubilee some [ __ ] the way
they edited this Lee asked her the
question first and then he cropped his
answer because they
no but but they knew yeah you can't dog
them for that but they know you gotta
give them what you got to give them yeah
I met it it's not misleading editing but
its position airstrike yes holiday if it
man killed me week you didn't see it
coming up from above it makes you feel
like that they doing a good job my
boyfriend a ok no yeah I mean yeah he
knows that in it but he doesn't want it
why your faith like that I don't care
how many times I hear that that's just
gross what's gross he's my boyfriend
she knows that but he doesn't want it
but he's my boyfriend
yeah but the thing is that your brain
now the weight of your brain functions
that you keep on switching it that if it
was a man saying that no but if it was a
man saying that it would be creepier
sure I think I'm just thinking back to
my past experiences and I feel like
girls have said this to me without
saying it girls have lived part of their
lives thinking I was their their
boyfriend even though I said I wasn't
and I remember how gross that was they
promised it to all their friends yeah
yeah I've had them introduce me is that
and it was something unconsented but
also really disturbing about the fact
that you are so insistent on living in
this life of yours when someone that you
visualize I mean you're forcing me into
this slot that I don't want to fit into
if someone introduces you as that you
call them out on this part or you wait
not hold them on the spot if we're in
front of people
I'll do it in private but otherwise if
we're in private I'll just talk to you
you know what this is why and I'll only
have this conversation twice I'll say it
the first time and the second time if I
see that you haven't gotten what you did
baby did well it's unhealthy because
you're not dating me you're dating this
idea and I'm if I don't fit it you're
not gonna see me that's a problem
there's people who've literally looked
at my behavior but that's unacceptable
like well this is how I always am but
you're too busy living in this fantasy
world that you think my behaviors out of
the norm like you know you didn't see me
but the thing is like I don't fear any
word and I don't fear any problems like
regarding a relationship he fears these
kind of things so for me this is like a
normal thing so this guy is my boyfriend
yes I want to see him when I have
every time I don't want to see another
one that's not the definition of a
boyfriend if the person that you like
but that's not sort of boyfriend maybe
it's cuz the age difference but I get
the impression that she thinks she knows
what's best for them and she's waiting
for him to see it that's what I
understood in her speech well I'd like
to go with the label lists are out I
like to think that we're just doing what
we're doing and they were having fun
doing it I think it's too soon to say
whether we are boyfriend or girlfriend
or not
but I do I do enjoy the time we spend
together and I think it's important too
yeah it's very important angry I know
you know it's another I know it's fine
I know I know all this I know it's fine
I just wait it out she just gave that
answer to everyone else who was looking
and so she's justifying I know what you
think I know this but it's okay doesn't
matter like if the what I think it is
but yeah and to be clear there's not a
referendum on her being just the way she
approaches a relationship you may not be
very good at creating or forming pawns
and still be a good person yeah yeah
yeah I love him I'm in three months in
that's intense but hey listen people
follow my first sight so I'm not going
to touch my body of course I think he's
amazing he's just otherworldly yeah I
don't think this is gonna be a cringe
report but there's something about women
who are like like you got [ __ ] angels
singing around you like Oh like it feels
like would people it just makes me
uneasy when people look at people like
yeah it's like someone looks at you like
you doesn't stink you just came out of
the bathroom like yeah that's definitely
stinks you know what I mean like I know
it stinks
like I couldn't smell myself I think so
it was a yes was it a yes jublia
campbell you asset this you really going
in
I haven't cringed this hard in a while
some being put on the spot like was
something like TV I would want to you
love him she said she loves you she's
looking at you like this and you could
see everyone in millions of people and
that is I'm putting myself in his shoes
and I'm like oh that's a conversation I
don't want to have in private but he
signed up for this yeah we'll see it was
a yes
is it a yes you know it already you can
feel it anyway yeah I can feel it yeah
so of course I love you
damn I do in one particular way I mean
I'm not even sure what love actually is
within myself so maybe I got to figure
that out before I start sending it out
to other people I don't want to give you
the wrong information
who knows if I'm right and then the age
gap just came back because you said he
was 24 I remember when I was 24 I know
you know I mean I took me from time to
time my girl I love you those words are
you still carry me over there if eyes
answered us makes me cringe it's what I
know her reaction is gonna be a
discussion just knowing you're doing
that to somebody I don't even know what
love is
so I even mad at him I said that before
man know the value of I love you
more than women because women use it a
lot more I love this I love that love
them shoes a love a love love love love
love you love me love me some fried
chicken
love me some ice cream love me some
better cherries let me some beans
let me some disks I mean someday
everything is love when your mom says I
love you it's like yeah mom I know you
said that three times today but when
your dad says I love you like oh all
right I hit that friend so yeah there is
opportunity you are so talented you
can't make it like really right here and
if you make it here you will make it
everywhere and you can because you are
like you have everything to do it like I
trust in you so much and this is not
only me
for some reason it's I'm kind of
resistant to believing these things yes
exactly what I was thinking oh man I
don't know what it is I felt like this
is DejaVu frees me up there's something
weird about when someone believes in you
so much and you really don't and it
almost feels like their words fall on
deaf ears do you know I mean because no
matter how much about your arts amazing
you just can't believe it because it
comes from that person this is what this
strikes me as and so actually striking I
can tell she's trying to reach him I'm
cringing because it's not working at all
but he's nice to know someone is trying
it's nice to like hit him in the chest
and it just rolls in on the floor I
don't know I need I think I need to work
on a form of acceptance but you know I'm
just for my whole life I'm just so used
to negative responses and rejections and
he could deal with that
see that's the thing he's used to
negative yeah so when you hear the
positive you just can't believe he's
like this is not real it's not real it's
not real remember I was I wasn't ever it
was new to that school right and I've
made some problems with this clique and
in a couple of months after that I
boarded them my eyes won't be like that
I'm not gonna cross your path I was all
but a girl came to me and it's like yeah
he just was in my class
part of that clique hey Mia no yo is the
other the queen bee of damn seems like a
number yeah no she wants me there's no
such thing as number you're not I mean
my number that is my mama yeah do you
want to go out with me I know I came out
with a no I'm like yo I was pissed off
yeah what the I thought it was a prank
I'm like what gives this I don't know
read it ya know tell your friend I ain't
about that life because this ain't daddy
know how your friends that we can't be
friends you know what it is because of
the trauma in the life I could take a
punch better than I can take a hug and
you know I almost longed for rejection
because that's all I know
but to hear you believe in me so much I
think you're slowly teaching me a
language that I'm starting to understand
and I really thank you for that and
that's why I really care about you I
think you're I think you're a beautiful
person I think you're extremely unique
and you're also also extremely talented
but on top of that you believe in
yourself like no other and that's
something the rest of the world needs to
learn it's like watching a long break up
yeah I have not cringed this much on the
inside and the outside I don't know if
it's a make up or break up you okay
okay I can't I do eventually this sounds
like a very good is this feels like I'm
watching two people naked talking and I
shouldn't be watching and it's making me
uneasy
which i think is the point of this
series but Wow I'm gonna cry but really
you got something special too and I
think I think everyone's starting to see
as well
just like
you crazy was just like if it was PDA
it's done first off I want to give a
shout out to Jubilee because we trashed
them all the time but I think the point
of the series was to show people being
very vulnerable be very candid and I
thought they did a really good job of
that the fact that I felt so much melt
that it was very good job so you have to
give them credit when we always track me
I can't no longer thrash them
I can't trash them no I can't no longer
it's faster I mean cuz they know they
make good content
you can't trash that much and beyond
these and commenting the that much and
at some point they know what they're
doing so I'm done with the trashing as
for this video to me it just felt like I
was watching a conversation I shouldn't
have that's what I found and made me
super uncomfortable because it wasn't
like a very cheerful but that's reality
and yeah it was good I think he's like
the best form of reality TV that makes
sense in that like you're not reality
TVs always curated for like drama and
nonsense this just seemed like it was
curated for leaving everything of the
reality TV within a short capsule no man
got that much of an attention span
anyways and he put it out there and they
do their thing
yeah but reality TV to me is geared
towards drama this didn't feel like it
was meant for drama it's a basic recipe
of reality TV you do the screening
process properly and the rest would
unfold and that's what happened sure try
I just think the goals of reality TV and
this are different reality TV is not
meant to be reality you think of course
not it's ridiculous the whole concept of
it is ridiculous you think they're
having conversations like that yeah I
think it's also a real reflection of how
they feel hmm yeah that felt like a very
honest conversation you know almost too
honest that that's why it made me
uncomfortable do you think what I'm
saying well she was very honest about
her views however problematic that we
feel it was we're in a different age
we're not at the reality TV anymore this
is a reality internet reality web that's
what it is it's realer yeah definitely
felt authentic um you know so good for
them for being able to share that they
have probably
courage in that department than I do
yeah I wouldn't god bless y'all we want
to know what you guys thought about some
of the ideas that we raised during this
about like attachment when she said my
boyfriend and all that yeah that was
intense but I've never cringed this hard
this is the hardest I've ever okay you
creatures harder that much when I feel
PD a faceful strategist I don't even
need to go that PDA yeah okay all right
no ways but we want to hear your
comments below what did you guys think
did you make it all the way through this
video yeah that's pretty much it okay
you go first
like any couple of this digital world we
met through social media specifically IG
Instagram you actually slid into my DMS
and you messaged me about my voice well
basically he like few of my pictures I
went on his profile and I got very
interested and I started liking and I
started like watching his videos what
he's doing and I've been really caught
with his voice and I just messaged him
and I I told him that he had an amazing
voice and we started talking like that
that always makes me uncomfortable
wait when someone's too into somebody
and there's a glowing as they said yeah
I don't know why it makes me cringe on
the inside it does nothing wrong with
down I'm not mad at cuz I know some
people expect but it to me is just like
you're suffocating but I'm not even in
that relationship and I feel like you
know what I mean I see myself pretty
objectively and I'm not that amazing so
when someone speaks to me like I'm Jesus
the second coming I'm just like oh yeah
I think what's suffocating about that is
that mmm my being is being erased by
your expectations and I can feel your
expectations overtaking who I actually
am so you're not saying yeah just don't
like compliments it's gonna be as simple
as that okay it's not gonna be like some
kind of oh you know what it is no I
don't I'm not a fan of column and I'm
like yeah thank you
you say oh I like what you do when I'm
gonna thank you very much what about
good compliments
with a bad compliment but there's
compliments like let's say if it's about
your sense of style whether like the way
you're dressed with anybody that alpha
is dope I've seen you take compliments
where you get a little bit excited like
oh okay
so friend yeah because I heard that
compliment before so I'm getting better
and better at it really it looks like
it's more genuine like I'm trained I'm
like a little Sheldon Cooper oh okay I
know I know this program so I know how
to I'm 24 the amount of like androgyny
popping out of these two it's worse on
this channel
oh is it pain I met my image of the
drogyn has always been Prince and I've
always been a good again you know I
whack so yeah I don't know that is I'll
post a little clip of Priest wagon it's
over that age difference only bothers
women when it clearly shows that you're
uncomfortable with it or you don't know
how to handle it I told you I lost my
virginity to a girl that was ten years
old when I was 18 right and subsequently
I dated a lot of women that were older
than me and they would bring it up at
first a black here or how old oh that's
too young and I was like listen
and I'm prom for me is it a problem for
you and then we just I was able to move
past yeah like so comfortable with it
after like but it's when you're not
comfortable with it that they can't get
around if you go with it yeah I get that
a lot
yes it's done so yeah if you like listen
I got time to drink that time toys we're
already here are we doing this yeah yeah
it's going like 160 watching this the
vibe I get from both of them is that
even though there's a huge age gap it
seems like their maturity level and
they're comfortable but it's around the
same oh yeah it is dude I've seen them a
couple of times in channel one is
Channel
[Music]
you've been to his channel before yeah
what kind of commentary stuff he's a fan
of our channel somebody they sent me one
of his videos I thought you got to watch
this on and I was like alright let's do
it he does cool [ __ ] does he yeah
alright I could like whenever I ask you
this position I'm like oh cool
he just has good commentary all right
cool let's find out